In today's video,
we've got Alex,
the host of the YouTube
channel "The Gripsion"
showing us how to make
a dry ice powered launcher.
[Music]
Guys, I'm Nate.
I'm Calli.
And I'm Alex from the YouTube
channel, The Gripsion.
We are going to be teaching
you guys how to make
an awesome dry ice launcher.
So Alex came up
with this very cool design,
and he came down from Canada
to show it off for us,
and to help us teach you
how to build one.
Here basic idea.
We'll glue some ABS
and PVC pipe together.
Then we'll add some dry ice
to build pressure to launch
gummy bears and [inaudible].
Okay. So Alex, what are the parts
that we need to make this?
So we have some ABS pipe here,
a couple of clean-out adapters,
a 3/4 inch ball valve.
So we have this pressure gauge,
and that will tell us
how much pressure we
are actually building.
We have a 3 inch piece
of 3/4 inch PVC pipe,
and then we have this 12 inch
3/4 inch piece of PVC pipe.
The last piece we need
for this dry ice launcher is
a pressure relief valve,
and this is going to ensure
that we don't build
too much pressure.
Very cool.
So it looks like we're going to be
building a chamber and a barrel,
and we're going to have
our PSI gauge to make sure we've
got a good amount of pressure,
and a safety valve to make sure
that nothing blows up on us.
Yeah.
Always a good plan.
So Alex, this is a launcher.
What can it launch?
All kinds of things.
Pretty much anything
that can fit in this diameter.
So if you had a small banana,
you could even just
stuff it in here.
But we like shoot gummies
and all kinds
of soft things like that
so it doesn't hurt if you
accidentally hit somebody.
So this is a large piece
of ABS piping,
and you can see
that Alex has already cut it
down to the length that we need,
which is 12 inches.
The first step in building
this launcher is going to be
to take the ABS glue,
and start putting some
of these pieces together.
[Music]
Let me see if it presses in,
if it doesn't,
you need to start getting ready
with the mallet right away.
That pressed pretty good.
Oh, but now I can't--
Well, it's glued.
Hit it with the mallet
just in case.
Good point.
Done.
Now, as you can see,
this glue kind of seeping out,
and we are just going to take
a paper towel and clean
that right up.
A note if you're trying
to glue ABS together,
you may have noticed
that I press it together,
and immediately tried
to twist it,
and I already couldn't.
That's because this glue
works so quickly,
it actually functions
by melting part
of the surface of the plastic,
and then as all
the solvents dissipate,
it like welds them together.
So it very
quickly goes together.
So you have to be ready
to the pieces together,
try and twist it if you can,
but just be aware,
you're not going
to be able to move it
once they've been put together.
They glue almost immediately.
[Music]
Three-- Three sets
of hands may have been a little
too much for this but...
No.
Okay.
More hands.
>> Okay. Okay. Oh no!
Oh no, it's on the table.
Alex, mallet, mallet.
I think that's gonna do it.
I think so too.
This piece is
completely done now.
So now, we are going
to drill a hole in here,
and then put some threads in it.
[Music]
So the plan here is
that we are going to be drilling
a hole just slightly
smaller into the threaded cap
than the pipe itself
just to make sure
that it fits really snugly.
Alright, so this is probably
going to be pretty tough.
So we might need pop
this back into the vice,
and use a wrench
so then we can kind of
really tightly screw this in.
[Music]
That's pretty good like that.
So now we are going
to unscrew it.
Now, we're going to use
our transition glue
to connect this PVC piece
on the ABS piece.
You have to make sure you're
using the right kind of glue,
because if you got
the wrong stuff,
it's not going to bond.
[Music]
All right.
This is on there really
well, so hopefully,
it makes a nice seal
so no pressure comes out.
All right.
So while we're
drilling and gluing,
we're also going to be adding
a pressure relief valve,
just to make sure
that everything is
where we need it to be.
We're also going to drill
a small hole that lets us put
in our pressure valve,
so we can see what
the pressure is.
For the pressure valve,
we are using--
We want a 1/2 inch drill bit.
[Music]
And now, we are going
to put this pressure
relief valve on it.
If you use tools
on the ABS, power tools,
it warms up a lot and gets
a little bit melty sometimes.
Now, we are going
to make some threads
and screw this in.
And because this is metal,
we don't need to make
threads ahead of time,
so we'll just screw
this right in.
[Music]
Okay, I think we've got
some good attachment there.
So now,
as we're holding this thing,
kind of like that,
we can see the PSI gauge.
I'm actually gonna go
a little bit more than that
because it's still
kind of on my arm,
and the goal is to make it
that if it does get
too much pressure,
and dump all the pressure out,
it's not going to hit us.
Now, we are just going
to screw this piece in,
and then attach the valve.
Yeah.
This isn't very tight fit.
So we'll fix that.
Now, we are going
to add some Teflon tape
to the end of this.
It's just going to give
it a nice strong seal
onto the valve
so no pressure gets released.
[Music]
So I think now it's
time to put a valve on,
and I'm just going
to make sure where it is,
so that's closed,
and we want to kind of
be holding a launcher like this.
So then right
when we open it,
it's just a nice fast opening.
So I think we'll screw
it on this way,
and that will be
the perfect angle.
Now, this is at the perfect spot
where I can look at the gauge,
and open it really fast.
This thing just looks cool.
Yeah.
And now, it's pretty much done.
How about let's hit it
with some spray paint?
Let's do it.
[Music]
As always with PVC
or ABS piping,
when you're putting on
the first layer of spray paint,
you want to make sure it's
a really light mist, dust coat,
because if you try
and put it on hard,
it's going to like
beat up and fish eye.
It won't look good.
[Music]
So now that the paint is dry,
now, we are going
to go test it.
What are we going to shoot?
Gummies.
Real quick.
Before we run outside
and test this thing out,
we want to give a shout out to
Alex's channel, The Gripsion.
Alex, tells about what you do.
So I make all kinds
of cool projects,
do super cool
science experiments,
and make awesome
projects all the time,
just like this one.
[Music]
All right.
So to make this work,
we're going to add just
a little bit of water,
about half a cup,
and then a little bit
of are broken up dry ice,
and it should start
building up pressure.
We'll have to watch
the pressure gauge to make sure
it's not getting too high.
[Music]
How much?
All right, that's
pretty good like that.
Just a couple pieces.
Yes?
Yes.
So the valve is open
at the moment,
so you can see we've just got
vapors pouring out the top.
And then once we
close the valve,
then it will start
building pressure.
So then we can load
some gummies in.
[Music]
Like a lot of gummy bears.
Okay.
More Gummy Bears.
It might be getting close
to the valve now.
Now, do you want to test that?
Sure.
Go for it.
All right.
So only at like 10 to 12 PSI.
So let's see if this works.
3, 2...
That went--
It's like a gummy bear shotgun.
Yes.
That's awesome.
Hey, you know
what you guys need now?
What?
A moving target.
Who's volunteering as tribute?
I volunteer as tribute.
[Music]
All right.
Let's get some more
Gummy Bears going.
Close the valve.
This is how you get
co-worker aggression out.
All right.
Moving target.
Say 1.
Give me like a 3, 2, 1.
3, 2, 1.
You missed.
They were all around you.
I win.
[Music]
Oh good.
Good, make it more dangerous.
Maybe aim up just a little bit,
because she's trying
to catch them this time.
3, 2, 1.
Well, I missed, but you got me.
3, 2...
I think I was close.
[Music]
There are piece
of grass on that.
Now that we've shot each other,
it's only fair
that we let Alex shoot us.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
I got one.
Nice.
3, 2, 1.
I got one.
I win.
[Music]
Nate's really upset
that I caught
the gummy bear last time,
and he didn't.
I don't want to talk about it.
3, 2, 1.
I got one.
Well...
Didn't uh...
This peg me in the face.
I'm gonna eat it now.
3, 2, 1.
That went really high.
Dang it, I missed it.
And over there.
Mostly over there.
I think Alex gets
most dedicated award.
He took off after that.
One hit me right in the glasses.
That's why you were the glasses.
Yeah, it was just
like, yoooo, bang!
[Music]
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
Hit that box up at the top
to go check out The Gripsion
on his channel.
That box down at
the bottom will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you're not subscribe
to our Channel,
hit this bomb to join the club,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.